when it comes to Summer it usually means
well taking a dip in the pool but a lot
of places are being impacted because
they simply cannot find enough
lifeguards and those impacts leading to
restricted hours and pools adjusting for
your safety eight news now reporter
Brian will dives into what this shortage
looks like right here in the valley
it's the last thing you think of when
you get into the
[Applause]
crucial role and you and your family's
safety and there's a dire shortage
so our hours did change unfortunately it
is affecting the community Rachel Harmon
is the Aquatic leader for the city of
Las Vegas and runs operations at the
Pavilion Center pool we did have to
reduce our hours unfortunately this
summer all six pools
operating seven days a week they have
limited hours on some days they're
closed on other days one of her
lifeguards Brevin Earl is feeling the
impact he's been a lifeguard for more
than three years I was the only one in
the shack and I'm hanging out there by
myself waiting to go up and man it full
time's stressed out because they've got
you know they don't have enough people
we're always getting called but it's not
all doomed with more money and
flexibility it's a job that anyone
comfortable in the water can do so back
in the day my classmates were my fellow
swim team members we were all strong
swimmers but now we see the teenagers
that want a summer paycheck we see the
adults and the seniors even that have
retired and they want to still make
money they are now hiring as young as 15
years old with a starting pay of 15 an
hour we want to make sure that
everybody's being safe and we will we're
going to keep doing that even if we're
understaffed or even if we don't have
enough people Las Vegas provides
lifeguard training for free and will
even pay recruits to learn the skills to
do the job reporting in Summerlin Brian
will 8 News Now